over the past decade the reputation of
oil companies has only gotten worse and
worse not only do they contribute to
climate change but they're also actively
draining earth's natural resources
so it's not surprising that many have
been supporting renewable forms of
energy as much as possible from buying
electric cars to installing solar panels
despite their efforts though our society
is still very much dependent on oil
whether it's to run our factories or to
fuel planes and it's no secret that oil
prices have skyrocketed over the past
several months
this has caused gas prices to reach
nearly five dollars per gallon across
the us while this is terrible for
everyday people who are just trying to
make ends meet this has been a blessing
for all companies exxon's net profits
for example have jumped from all-time
lows to multi-year highs and this hasn't
the stock soaring from the pandemic
bottom exxon has skyrocketed 250
which correlates to a market cap gain of
314 billion dollars this has served oil
investors like warren buffett extremely
well
but this is also a terrible economic
sign and here's why
before we jump into why this is terrible
for the economy we should first take a
look at why oil prices are skyrocketing
in the first place at first glance it's
easy to just blame higher oil prices on
sky high inflation but really it's not
as simple as that there's a multitude of
reasons behind this rise starting with
unprecedented surge in demand most
people have been cooped up inside their
homes ever since the pandemic started
and now that covert cases are finally
subsiding people are more excited than
ever to leave their city state or even
country whether it's a simple vacation
or a trip to meet family in different
states or countries people are willing
to spend significant amounts to get out
and given that the aviation industry
accounts for 7.8 percent of global oil
consumption it's not surprising that
this v-shaped recovery in airline demand
has contributed to a v-shaped recovery
in oil prices
but the contribution of airlines is
nothing in comparison to the
contribution of road-based vehicles
which has also boomed we're seeing more
people go to stores malls theaters
concerts music festivals road trips etc
but even more importantly most companies
have started to call back their remote
employees which has led to one-hour
commutes becoming the norm once again
for many and with passenger cars and
freight vehicles accounting for 49.3
percent of global oil consumption it's
no wonder that a return to normalcy has
increased demand substantially aside
from increasing demand we've also been
facing a major geopolitical conflict
which is of course the russia ukraine
war much of the world decides with
ukraine and to show their allegiance
they've been boycotting russian goods
the us for example has shut off imports
of russian oil natural gas and coal
russia only accounts for about 10 of the
global oil supply but this itself makes
them one of the top three oil producers
in the world only beaten up by the us
and saudi arabia so cutting off russian
oil not only reduces supply but it also
gives other oil producers more pricing
power one of the main reasons that oil
got so cheap during the pandemic was
actually thanks to russia you see russia
and saudi arabia were having an oil war
during the pandemic which pumped up oil
production to 30-year highs while demand
was at all-time lows this even led to
oil prices going negative momentarily
but now we no longer have russia to play
these crazy commodity games and speaking
of commodity games the people who are
most notorious for such games are no
doubt wall street a solid portion of
wall street has been speculating for all
prices to go up ever since the pandemic
started but wait a minute how does wall
street buying oil features have anything
to do with oil prices themselves after
all it's not like hedge funds are
directly buying barrels of oil they're
basically just betting on whether oil
will go up or down in the coming months
and years
well here's the thing when wall street
has optimistic expectations for oil
prices oil producers are less willing to
sell their oil because theoretically
according to wall street they should be
able to sell the oil for a higher price
in the future on the flip side while
consumers get more desperate to buy oil
right now because according to wall
street it's only going to get more
expensive so while wall street does not
directly contribute to the supply and
demand of oil they play quite a
significant psychological role and when
you combine historic inflation a
v-shaped recovery and demand the russian
boycott and wall street speculation it's
no wonder why oil prices are going to
the moon
now that we have a better understanding
as to why all prices are skyrocketing in
the first place we can move on to its
impact on the economy in terms of
microeconomics i don't even think i need
to explain anything for most of us gas
isn't essential you need it to go to
work shop for groceries drop kids off at
school etc even if you rely on public
transportation like buses and subways
it's only a matter of time until ticket
prices and annual passes increase
accordingly so sooner or later we'll all
be forced to allocate more money towards
transportation for many this increase is
unfortunately enough to break the bank
especially for those living in high cost
states like california but even if
you're able to afford the increased cost
your remaining budget will no doubt
decrease which means less discretionary
spending and the given that consumer
spending is directly linked to gdp this
is not the best of signs to make things
worse it's not just everyday people who
are feeling the weight of increasing oil
prices companies are very much feeling
the impact as well
now of course there are companies that
aren't dependent on a physical product
like facebook or google but most
companies do rely on shipping in one
form or another whether we're talking
about apple and amazon or nvidia and
tesla and as oil prices boom so does the
transportation expenses for these
companies
also many of these companies already run
on extremely thin profit margins so
increased logistical expenses alone are
not enough to push them into
unprofitability for example even amazon
who has one of the most established and
efficient logistical channels in the
world is feeling the pain
last quarter amazon's retail business
was unprofitable both in north america
and internationally usually this
wouldn't be that big of a problem as
companies can just pass on the increased
cost to customers but given that
customers already have less
discretionary income they're more
sensitive to price increases in fact one
survey found that one in three prime
members were considering cancelling
their subscriptions due to their price
hikes at the beginning of the year so
many companies are stuck in the
situation where they have increasing
expenses but stagnating or even
declining revenue this problem is made
even worse when you consider that
companies won't be able to achieve the
same economies of scale with less
revenue so their cost per dollar of
revenue just becomes even worse and in
such circumstances there's only one
obvious option and that's layoffs we're
already seeing a slew of signs that
companies are getting desperate to hold
up revenue for example we're hearing
rumors that amazon might have another
prime day in the fall and the timing of
this is especially concerning the fall
is usually the best time for companies
thanks to the holiday season so if
amazon is already trying to boost
numbers for this fall how bad will
demand be in q1 and q2 of next year
clearly it this is not a good sign and
if oil prices continue to stay at
historically high levels things will
likely only get worse
as companies earnings slide and people
spend less money we'll see the rest of
the economy follow a downward trend as
well here's the thing when companies
earnings are declining who wants to be
investing in companies now of course
some of you contrarians out there are
saying that this is the best time to buy
fundamentally strong companies for the
long term and you may very well be right
but the mob is not on your side if they
were the stock market wouldn't be going
down in the first place so this means
that we're not only facing decreasing
consumer spending but we're also facing
decreasing investing usually in such
scenarios the government would pump up
spending but they're also pulling back
substantially to fight high inflation so
consumption investment and government
spending are all going down meaning that
our gdp is basically screwed at least in
the short medium term and given that a
recession is defined by two successive
quarters of gdp decline chances are
pretty good that we enter a recession
skyrocketing oil prices have actually
been extremely good at predicting
recessions historically
not every recession is characterized by
high oil prices but every time oil
spikes we have a recession and this has
been true since the 1940s between 1946
and 1948 we saw oil prices nearly double
and shortly after we saw a recession
between 1948 and 1949. similarly between
1973 and 1974 oil prices nearly tripled
and we once again saw a recession we saw
the same thing between 1979 and 1980 and
1990 1991 and 1998 and 2000 and 2007 and
2008.
in fact i don't think there's a single
time in this 70 year graph where oil
prices spiked and there wasn't a
recession now of course correlation does
not mean causation but considering all
the reasoning that we've already
discussed it doesn't seem like this is
just a coincidence either to make things
worse the most recent spike is more
violent than we've ever seen with oil
rocketing from 20 to 110 within a matter
of two years so based on history things
aren't looking that bright
while we may very well be in for a
painful recession and rising
unemployment there are some bright spots
to look forward to not all recessions
are accompanied by stock market crash
but given how the market has been
performing so far it definitely looks
like this recession is being accompanied
by stock market crash on average indices
typically peaked seven months before
recession and they bottom four months
before the end of recession given that
the s p 500 peaked in december that
would mean that the recession is
starting right now
as for the housing market i don't think
there's going to be a full-on crash like
2008 but a cooldown is extremely likely
and this could help many people buy
their first home without having to bid
insane amounts over asking aside from
providing a great buying opportunity
recessions generally wipe out the
garbage on the market and there's no
doubt loads of garbage within the stock
market and especially the cryptocurrency
market i mean i don't think we need to
even discuss nfts or all the dog face
coins on the market so this could be a
great time to cleanse the space and
start fresh there may be some
non-financial benefits as well with the
gas prices being so high it's likely
that many upper middle class families
will make the jump to evs and this would
be a great boost for the entire industry
but most importantly a recession may
help cool down the out-of-control
inflation that we're currently facing
and that may be just what we need to
transition it into a new period of
growth and prosperity but that's just
what i think do you think we're in a
recession comment that down below
also drop a like if you can't wait to
get to the other side of this recession
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing and
see more questions that logically
answered but until then i'm hari and
i'll see you guys on the next one